[Musique]
combien croyez-vous qu'il y ait de pâte
à puch qu'il ne faut trop échos monte
bien sûr toi moi d'abord parce que
attention il manque
[Musique]
par taqa je m'ennuie pas car je m'amuse
kobasew joly a pas eu jamie aujourd'hui
avec moi dix mots
assieds toi là maintenant je m'attends
quand j'en fais tu te perds et tu
écoutes une très belle histoire sciences
l'était devant elle elle était devant
lui
les étés lait devant l'autre
ces bacs ton histoire est muté s'y
sentir heureux au cachet sapir m
[Musique]
patate loup je mens nous fait comme moi
d'or j'ai pas ça me vient jouer avec moi
l'on joue tout ce en quoi est ce que tu
veux j'ai pas dit de installe toi un
bateau et fiches mais la paix mais quel
genre de bateau bon ben j'ai compris
j'ai compris
[Musique]
je crois que ça non plus ce n'était pas
une bonne idée ne peut pas se faire
prends ça et encore sans emballage
j'agis natale heures
lapierre a pas des sept mers et vous
avez pêche pas de moi
[Musique]
oh
à pâques nous rendent à bâton pourquoi
abattant un bateau dans le jardin je
t'ai dit de jouer tout seul geste moi
dormir
[Rires]
pourtant j'ai bien vu un bateau je veux
atteindre le pirate à la fenêtre
regardez je vois surtout un affreux
petit menteur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
au jeu le but le pirate jamais vu sur
les joues tu verras bien qu'il n'ya rien
[Musique]
ça vous apprendra à faire moins de bruit
[Rires]
convié toyer vous qu'il y ait de pâte à
pêcher le faux trompez pas compter bien
sûr vaudois
d'autre part il me manque
[Musique]